From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是由国际公共广播电台发行的《美国生活》。
We had both been dating the same person, and she had been dating him for a while, and then broken it off. And then I had met him, and so he and I were dating. And then he started talking about her.
我们当时都在和同一个人约会，她和他在一起有一段时间了，后来分开了。然后我遇见了他，所以我和他在交往。接着他开始提起她。
Oh, Julie, she's just this fantastic artist, and she lives in a trailer in the woods. And I go out there and drink wine with her and listen to fabulous music, and we just have deep intellectual conversations, that kind of stuff. And it turned out that he was seeing both of us at the same time.
哦，朱莉，她是一位非常出色的艺术家，住在一片树林里的拖车里。我会去那里和她一起喝红酒，听美妙的音乐，我们只会进行深刻的智力对话，诸如此类。结果发现他当时同时在和我们两人交往。
It took a while to figure that out, though. And in the meantime, this guy had the sheer nerve to introduce the two women to each other, Erin and Julie. And they became friends. And things kind of exploded with the guy and they stayed friends, at first with him, and then after that, with each other, in this emotional purgatory that I think most of us would never put up with after our 20s, which is exactly how old they were.
不过，花了点时间才弄清楚这一点。与此同时，这家伙竟然有胆量把这两个女人——艾琳和朱莉——介绍给彼此认识。她们成了朋友。事情在那个男人的问题上有点爆发了，起初她们和他保持朋友关系，后来她们成了彼此的朋友，处在一种我认为大多数人在20岁之后绝不会忍受的情感炼狱中，而那正是她们当时的年纪。
It was just kind of a weird, close friendship because it revolved around us not liking this guy, and that's kind of what it was based on at first. Even though we both knew that we kind of didn't like each other either. Because we both really secretly did like this guy, and wanted him to like us. And we just resented each other for even being in the picture. I don't know.
这是一种很奇怪的亲密友谊，因为它围绕着我们不喜欢这个男人而展开，起初基本上就是基于这个。尽管我们俩都知道其实我们也不怎么喜欢对方。因为我们私下里都很喜欢这个男人，都希望他喜欢我们。我们因为对方出现在这幅画面里而怨恨彼此。我不知道。
That was Erin. Here's Julie.
那是艾琳。接下来是朱莉。
I believed that we just happened to have a bad beginning, and that if we had met under different circumstances-- and she said the same thing-- if we'd met under different circumstances, we probably wouldn't have created all that bad history, this like push me, pull you kind of relationship.
我相信我们只是有个糟糕的开端，如果我们在不同的情况下相遇——她也说了同样的话——如果我们是在不同的情况下相遇，我们可能就不会制造出所有那些糟糕的历史，这种像“推我拉你”一样的关系。
And they continued this way, as frenemies, having fun together now and then, but also getting into these huge, horrible fights all the time for four years. Long after they both stopped talking to the guy. And the real question is, when you're in this kind of situation-- and who among us has not been in this situation where you have some friend, where the thought of hanging out with his friend totally stresses you out. And you think, are we really friends then? The question is, why don't you cut it off?
她们就这样以这种“亦敌亦友”的方式持续了四年，偶尔一起玩得很开心，但也总是陷入巨大的、可怕的争吵。在她们俩都不再和那个男人说话很久之后。真正的问题是，当你处在这种情况下时——我们谁没遇到过这种情况呢？你有个朋友，一想到要和这个朋友待在一起就让你感到非常有压力。你会想，那我们真的还是朋友吗？问题是，为什么你不切断这段关系呢？
And it turns out this is a question that science has actually looked into. Science done by a psychologist named Julianne Holt-Lunstad and her colleagues.
结果证明，这是一个科学已经研究过的问题。这项科学研究是由一位名叫朱莉安·霍尔特-伦斯塔德及其同事的心理学家完成的。
Well, of course, our guiding question was, well if these relationships are potentially detrimental, why would people keep them?
嗯，当然，我们的指导问题是：如果这些关系可能是有害的，为什么人们还要维持它们呢？
Julianne Holt-Lunstad has done a number of studies on ambivalent and frustrating friendships. In one of them, she had people rate their friends and their family members. How supportive they are, how much stress they cause, on and on. And she found that half, half of our relationships, on average, are with people that we care a lot about, we feel positive towards, and we also have real conflicts and negative feelings about as well.
朱莉安·霍尔特-伦斯塔德对这种矛盾且令人沮丧的友谊进行了多项研究。在其中一项研究中，她让人们对他们的朋友和家人进行评价。评价他们有多支持自己，他们造成了多大的压力，等等。她发现，平均而言，我们一半的关系是与那些我们非常在乎、对此怀有积极态度，但同时也确实存在冲突和负面感受的人建立的。
People talk about friends that are tons of fun, but can be really competitive. A friend that is really great when they're around, but are incredibly unreliable, or can be really insensitive at times.
人们谈论那些非常有趣但可能极具竞争性的朋友。一个在身边时非常好，但极其不可靠，或者有时非常迟钝的朋友。
I recall one person even saying, "I stick around for those few times that she is good to me and is nice. But most of time it's not good."
我记得有人甚至说：“我留下来是因为那些她对我好、对我友善的少数时刻。但大多数时候情况并不好。”
When Hold-Lunstad and a colleague began their examination of why we don't just break up with these friends, they had a hypothesis. They thought, there must be external factors that made ditching these friends really, really hard. Like they're friends with all your other friends, or your kids are close, or you're part of the same church.
当霍尔特-伦斯塔德和一位同事开始研究我们为什么不直接与这些朋友断绝关系时，他们有一个假设。他们认为，一定存在一些外部因素让抛弃这些朋友变得非常、非常困难。比如他们是你所有其他朋友的朋友，或者你们的孩子很亲近，或者你们属于同一个教会。
Or they're your next door neighbor. What are you going to do, move? You basically run in the same social circles, and so it may be very difficult to avoid this person. And so you've got these barriers to ending that relationship.
或者他们是你的隔壁邻居。你要怎么办，搬家吗？你基本上处在相同的社交圈里，所以可能很难避开这个人。于是你有了终结这段关系的障碍。
But to their surprise, they found this is not why people stay in these troubling friendships. People stay, they found, for reasons that they impose on themselves. Either they tell themselves things like, I'm not the kind of person who just gives up on somebody. I stay friends. Or they tell themselves that the good times outweigh the bad. Like with these two women, Erin and Julie.
但令他们惊讶的是，他们发现这并不是人们留在这些麻烦友谊中的原因。他们发现，人们留下来是因为他们强加给自己的原因。要么他们告诉自己一些事情，比如，我不是那种轻易放弃别人的人。我留下来做朋友。或者他们告诉自己，好的时光多于坏的。就像这两位女性，艾琳和朱莉一样。
They stayed frenemies for years because they got something from it. They got caught up in this competitive thing where Julie would give Erin advice, and Erin would like the advice, or not like the advice. And somehow neither of them could let that go.
她们做了多年的“亦敌亦友”，因为她们从中得到了些什么。她们陷入了这种竞争的事情中，朱莉会给艾琳建议，艾琳要么喜欢这个建议，要么不喜欢。不知何故，她们俩谁都无法放手。
I guess we are both attracted to defending our own honor. And we liked to write, so a lot of the time we would write long emails about-- no, no, no. This is why you suck. This is not actually what happened and let me point out to you this. So her logic in the emails just seemed so flawed, I just wanted to like, no, no. No, that's not how things went down. I just wanted to defend myself to her. And then, I guess we both thought that the other person should be the one to cut it off.
我想我们都被捍卫自己的荣誉所吸引。我们喜欢写作，所以很多时候我们会写长长的电子邮件关于——不，不，不。这就是你烂透了的原因。事情其实不是这样发生的，让我向你指出这一点。所以她在邮件里的逻辑看起来太有缺陷了，我只是想，不，不。不，事情不是那样发生的。我只是想向她为自己辩护。然后，我想我们俩都认为对方应该是那个切断关系的人。
I don't know why I feel like it would be horrible for me to say, OK, we're done with this. And now let's kind of go on our separate ways.
我不知道为什么我觉得如果我来说“好吧，我们结束了。现在让我们各走各的路吧”会很可怕。
In another study, Julianne Holt-Lunstad and her colleagues wired people up to take their blood pressure every time they interacted with another person for three full days and found that friends that we feel ambivalently about raise our blood pressure more, cause more anxiety and stress than people that we actively dislike. In other words, frenemies are bad for our health. And they're all around us, 50% of our relationships. And today on our radio show, we examine them in all of their nefarious forms. The ones that we can only blame ourselves for having, the ones who simply cause agita without meaning any harm against us, and of course, the very few who actively scheme against us like characters on a TV soap opera. Smiling to our faces and then quietly going off and doing things that we do not like from friends or anybody else.
在另一项研究中，朱莉安·霍尔特-伦斯塔德和她的同事让人们接上线路，在整整三天里，每次与他人互动时都测量他们的血压，结果发现，我们感到矛盾的朋友比我们积极厌恶的人更能升高我们的血压，导致更多的焦虑和压力。换句话说，“亦敌亦友”对我们的健康有害。他们就在我们周围，占我们关系的50%。今天在我们的广播节目中，我们审视了他们所有邪恶的形式。那些我们只能怪自己交了这种朋友，那些仅仅在没有恶意的情况下引起我们烦躁的人，当然，还有极少数像肥皂剧里的角色那样积极谋划对付我们的人。当面微笑，然后悄悄地去做那些我们不喜欢朋友或任何人做的事情。
We hear all these types today, our show in four acts. Act one, Chasing Amy. What do you do when you're not sure but you think maybe your sister is starting to act like your frenemy? Act two, I am Here to Make Frenemies. In which we head into what we believe might be the world capital of frenemy behavior. Act three, Speak Now or Forever Hold Your Peace. David Rakoff in that act, and an impossible wedding toast, in rhyme. Act four, The Case of the Long Lost Frenemy, in which a childhood friend mysteriously shows up after years for reasons that are revealed over time. Stay with us.
今天我们将听到所有这些类型，我们的节目分四幕。第一幕，《追逐艾米》。当你拿不准，但你觉得也许你的姐姐开始表现得像你的“亦敌亦友”时，你该怎么办？第二幕，《我来这里不是为了交朋友》。我们前往我们认为可能是世界“亦敌亦友”行为之都的地方。第三幕，《现在说出来，否则永远保持沉默》。大卫·拉科夫在这一幕中，还有一场不可能的婚礼祝酒词，以押韵的形式呈现。第四幕，《失踪的“亦敌亦友”案》，一位童年朋友在多年后神秘出现，原因随着时间推移揭晓。请留下。
"Act one, Chasing Amy."
“第一幕，追逐艾米”。
Family members can so easily be frenemies because you're stuck with them and you love them, and they sometimes do things that make you feel very weird. Jeanne Darst tells this story about herself and her sister.
家庭成员很容易成为“亦敌亦友”，因为你被困在他们身边，你爱他们，但他们有时做的事情会让你感觉非常奇怪。珍妮·达斯特讲述了关于她自己和她姐姐的故事。
Amy's estrangement went undiagnosed for some time. Because in our family, someone retreating in anger is hardly a bacon cooler. People are always suddenly putting on their coats and requesting a ride to the Metro North Station, and my therapist said no contact for six months, and you can't come if you're drinking, and I won't come if he's there. And I'll come, but don't sit me next to her.
艾米的疏远有一段时间没有被诊断出来。因为在我们家里，有人愤怒地撤退绝不是什么稀奇事。人们总是突然穿上大衣，要求搭车去大都会北站，我的治疗师说六个月内不联系，如果你在喝酒就别来，如果他在那里我就不来。我会来，但别把我安排在她旁边坐。
I always picture a sweaty John Madden frantically scribbling our Thanksgiving plays on a blackboard. So it took some time to notice, but maybe estrangement is by definition a matter of time. This is how it went.
我总是想象一个汗流浃背的约翰·麦登在黑板上疯狂地涂写我们的感恩节战术。所以花了一段时间才注意到，但也许疏远按定义就是时间问题。事情是这样的。
Our white Volvo sulks through the traffic up the West Side Highway. My brother-in-law, Henry, is driving and I'm in the back seat behind him. His wife, my sister Liz, is in the passenger seat, and behind her is her four-year-old, Luisa, in her car seat.
我们的白色沃尔沃在西区高速公路的拥堵中闷闷不乐地行驶。我的姐夫亨利在开车，我坐在他后面的后座上。他的妻子，我的姐姐莉兹，坐在副驾驶座上，她后面是她四岁的女儿路易莎，坐在儿童安全座椅里。
We're like two car fractions. Henry and Liz being the numerators, Luisa and I, the denominators. We're on our way to Jersey City to meet our sister, Amy's, new husband, a Muslim from Tunis she met in an Arab chat room, moved in with, and married at the City Hall in Philadelphia in just under six weeks, [? Waleed. ?] My mother called me as soon as she got the news.
我们就像两个汽车分数。亨利和莉兹是分子，路易莎和我，是分母。我们正在前往泽西市去见我们姐姐艾米的新丈夫，一个来自突尼斯、她在阿拉伯聊天室认识、搬去和他同住并于六周内在费城市政厅结婚的穆斯林，[？瓦利德？]。我妈妈一得到消息就给我打了电话。
Apparently they met in a chat room, she tells me, whatever the hell that means. And he cooked her a lot of Tunisian dishes, and then he whisked her off and married her.
显然他们是在聊天室认识的，她告诉我，管那是什么鬼意思。他给她做了很多突尼斯菜，然后他就带她跑了并娶了她。
Wow. I wouldn't mind seeing what he's putting in those dishes, I say.
哇。我不介意看看他在那些菜里加了什么，我说。
Oh, I think a lot of coriander. Probably cumin, garlic. That would be my guess. Now let me ask you something, Jeanne. Don't you think it's just a little peculiar getting married so fast? We haven't even met this [? Waleed ?] character.
哦，我想很多香菜。可能是孜然，大蒜。我会猜是这样。现在让我问你一件事，珍妮。你不觉得结婚这么快有点奇怪吗？我们甚至还没见过这个[？瓦利德？]角色。
Well, this is the same woman who went on a second date to Chile I point out.
嗯，这就是那个第二次约会就去了智利的同一个女人，我指出。
That's right. What was she thinking? She could have been murdered.
没错。她在想什么？她可能已经被谋杀了。
The guy went to Dalton, Mom.
那个人去了道尔顿学校，妈。
That doesn't mean anything, what about the preppy murderer?
那什么也代表不了，那个常春藤盟校的杀手呢？
Robert Chambers didn't go to Dalton.
罗伯特·钱伯斯没去过道尔顿。
Oh, for God's sakes, Jeanne. Be serious. Now, did you ever see the movie Green Card with Andie MacDowell? All right, well she plays an American woman who meets a Frenchman.
哦，看在上帝的份上，珍妮。严肃点。现在，你看过安迪·麦克道威尔演的电影《绿卡》吗？好吧，她演一个美国女人认识了一个法国人。
Mom, I know what a green card situation is.
妈，我知道什么是绿卡情况。
Well, all right, [? dolly. ?] I didn't think you knew what these people do. I'm highly upset over here.
好吧，[？亲爱的？]。我没想到你知道这些人做什么。我在这里非常心烦。
My mother has a few stock phrases. Highly upset is a big one. I don't know that she's ever been regular upset. She prefers to head straight to highly. I'm not so much supportive of Amy's hasty act as I am invigorated. Just the idea of having dinner with that kind of recklessness has perked my spirits up.
我妈妈有一些常用短语。“非常心烦”是一个常用的。我不知道她是否曾经有过正常的心烦。她更喜欢直接进入“非常”状态。我对艾米的仓促行为与其说支持，不如说是感到振奋。只要想到和那种鲁莽的人一起吃晚餐，我的精神就为之一振。
What is with this traffic, Henry says. Liz has thrown my big, black scarf over Luisa's head to block the sunlight so she can nap. We giggle when we see the effect the scarf creates, which is that of a burqa. Cover her ankles, Liz jokes.
这交通是怎么回事，亨利说。莉兹已经把我的大黑围巾扔在路易莎的头上挡住阳光，这样她就可以打盹了。当我们看到围巾造成的效果时，我们咯咯笑起来，那就像一件罩袍。遮住她的脚踝，莉兹开玩笑说。
This day doesn't feel unfamiliar. Beginning with Amy's first boyfriend, my parents were "highly upset." J.J. was a mechanic from Tuckahoe, the next town over from ours. He listened to Van Halen, didn't plan on going to college, and reeked of Polo cologne.
这一天并不让人感到陌生。从艾米的第一个男朋友开始，我父母就“非常心烦”。J.J.是一个来自塔卡霍的机械师，那是我们隔壁的镇子。他听范·海伦的歌，没打算上大学，身上充满了Polo古龙水的味道。
I'd be smoking, drinking some stolen warm beers up in my room, chatting on the phone, when a waft of that signature Ralph Lauren scent would hit me. Soon enough, our older sister, Liz, would fly in and shut my door.
我当时正在房间里抽烟，喝着偷来的温啤酒，打着电话，当那股标志性的拉夫·劳伦香味飘到我身边时。很快，我们的姐姐莉兹就会飞进来关上我的门。
Sheesh, the front hall smells like the ground floor of Bloomingdale's. God.
啧，前厅闻起来像布鲁明戴尔百货的一楼。天哪。
My parents had strategy sessions about J.J., held late at night in their bedroom after they'd both had quite a bit of red wine with dinner and a couple scotches. I'd be coming up from the kitchen and they'd trap me for a night cap interrogation.
我父母深夜在他们的卧室里举行关于J.J.的战略会议，在他们晚餐时都喝了不少红酒和几杯苏格兰威士忌之后。我从厨房上来，他们就会抓住我进行睡前审讯。
Oh, Jeanne, Doris would yell from her bed throne. Come here for a minute my mother would say, casually, as if she were not asking you to make a quick betrayal of your sister before hitting the sack.
哦，珍妮，多丽丝会从她的床位宝座上大叫。过来一下，我妈妈会随口说，就好像她不是让你在睡觉前迅速背叛你的姐姐一样。
We want to talk to you about this J.J. character, Jeanne [? Jo. ?] Even by his fourth child, my dad was still tinkering with his father persona. I sat on the gold satin divan, shut my eyes, and stretched my legs, as if I were merely there to maintain my base tan.
我们想和你谈谈这个J.J.角色，珍妮[？乔？]。即使到了他的第四个孩子，我爸爸仍在修补他的父亲形象。我坐在金色缎面长沙发上，闭上眼睛，伸展双腿，仿佛我只是在那里维持我的底色晒黑。
Dammit, Jeanne [? Jo ?], your mother's talking to you.
该死，珍妮[？乔？]，你妈妈在和你说话。
Is he a thug, my mother repeated.
他是暴徒吗，我妈妈重复道。
Well, what's the strict definition of a--
嗯，暴徒的严格定义是什么——
Someone who's having sex with Amy, my mother blurted.
一个和艾米发生性关系的人，我妈妈脱口而出。
All right, let's all settle down my father said. We're way off track here. Now how well do you know J.J.?
好了，大家都冷静点，我爸爸说。我们离题太远了。现在你有多了解J.J.？
I don't.
我不了解。
He seems a bit wayward. Is that your impression?
他看起来有点任性。这是你的印象吗？
I think Amy's smoking pot, my mother added. You can smell it a mile away.
我想艾米在吸大麻，我妈妈补充道。你在几英里外就能闻到。
My father paused for a moment. Maybe that's why he wears so much cologne.
我父亲停顿了片刻。也许这就是为什么他喷那么多古龙水。
Steve, please, my mother yelled, putting out one of the two lit cigarettes she had going in the ashtray.
史蒂夫，求你了，我妈妈喊道，熄灭了她在烟灰缸里点燃的两支香烟中的一支。
Can I go to bed? I asked.
我可以去睡觉吗？我问。
Yes, yes. We're not going to solve anything tonight, my dad said.
是的，是的。我们今晚解决不了任何问题，我爸说。
You just couldn't outlast these two, long distance meddlers. They could go on forever.
你就是无法熬过这两个长途的干预者。她们可以永远说下去。
Amy and I were the close ones when we were younger. As little kids, when we had no money to go to the movies, we'd get a basket and go up to fancy houses on Egypt Lane, cutting people's flowers out front, putting them in the basket, and then ringing their doorbell and selling them their own flowers. Those people thought we were frigging adorable, and we made some decent money.
艾米和我很亲近，当我们更小的时候。作为小孩，当我们没钱去看电影时，我们会拿个篮子去埃及巷的高档房子，剪下别人前院的花，放进篮子里，然后按门铃把它们的花卖回给他们。那些人觉得我们可爱得要命，我们赚了不少钱。
We drank, we smoked around the house, we snickered at curfews and poo-pooed the law. Amy took my road test for me when I was 16. But at some point, after college I guess, Amy started to seem less rebellious and fun, and more bitter and suspicious.
我们喝酒，在家里抽烟，对宵禁嗤之以鼻，对法律表示不屑。当我16岁时，艾米帮我参加了路考。但有那么一刻，我想是在大学之后，艾米看起来不那么叛逆和有趣了，变得更痛苦和多疑了。
I remember more than once being on the subway with her, and her glaring at me to keep it down when I'd been talking about, say, whether we should get pizza or burritos for dinner.
我记得不止一次在地铁上和她在一起，当我谈论比如我们晚餐应该吃披萨还是墨西哥卷饼时，她瞪着我让我小声点。
Jesus, Jeanne, keep it down, she'd whisper.
天哪，珍妮，小声点，她会低声说。
She never cleaned. When I'd visit her place and see the dishes piled up, her sheets sort of half on, half off, I was often tempted to ask, what band is living here with you? When the shower broke in her apartment, instead of having it fixed she told me, I just shower at the gym now. Which was confusing because she didn't work out.
她从不打扫。当我拜访她的住处看到盘子堆积如山，床单半挂着，我经常想问，什么乐队和你住在这里？当她的公寓淋浴器坏了，她没去修理，而是告诉我，我现在在健身房洗澡。这令人困惑，因为她不去健身。
She seemed to still see the world from a teenager's perspective. If you commented on her Don King hair she might snap, everyone in this family is so totally judgmental and superficial. And she was probably right, but by 30 it was a slightly stale pose to strike.
她似乎仍然从十几岁的角度看世界。如果你评论她的唐·金式发型，她可能会突然说，这个家里的每个人都太爱评头论足、肤浅了。她可能是对的，但到了30岁，那是一个稍微陈旧的姿态。
Her relationships, romantic or otherwise, tended to end badly, and it was invariably the other person's fault. One day when I asked how Mark, her filmmaker boyfriend at NYU, was, she said matter-of-factly-- past tense-- he claims I tried to strangle him at the Lion's Head last weekend and now he won't return my calls. Total psycho.
她的关系，无论是浪漫的还是其他的，往往以糟糕的结局告终，而且总是对方的错。有一天，当我问马克，她在纽约大学的电影制片人男朋友怎么样时，她一本正经地——过去式——说，他说上周末在狮子头酒吧我试图勒死他，现在他不回我的电话。彻头彻尾的疯子。
She disliked everyone more and more. And at some point, that included me. One night I was drunk and flirting with the man who was about to take her to Chile for their second date. And I said to him, you should take me to Chile, I'm a lot more fun. Truly jerky thing to say, and I apologized more than once, but apologies have never impressed Amy. I was banished to some otherness, a place where suburban a-holes and parents who didn't approve of blue collar boyfriends went. And there seemed to be no getting back in.
她越来越讨厌所有人。在某一时刻，那也包括我。一天晚上我喝醉了，在和一个即将带她去智利进行第二次约会的男人调情。我对他说，你应该带我去智利，我有趣得多。真是太混蛋的话了，我道歉不止一次，但道歉从未给艾米留下深刻印象。我被放逐到另一个地方，那个郊区的混蛋和不赞成蓝领男朋友的父母所在的地方。似乎没有回来的路。
As we drive around looking for Amy's new house, I realize I do know something about [? Waleed. ?] Amy called me a couple weeks after they met and said she was seeing this new guy and that he had a really big-- you know. But when the phone call came on Easter Sunday that Amy had run off and married some Muslim from Tunis no one had met, I didn't think, everybody stay calm, I talked to Amy about this guy two weeks ago, he's got a big penis, would quiet my parents' concerns.
当我们开车寻找艾米的新房子时，我意识到我确实知道一些关于[？瓦利德？]的事。他们见面几周后艾米给我打电话，说她在和一个新男人约会，他有一个真的很大——你知道的。但当复活节周日那个电话打来，说艾米跑掉并嫁给了一个没人见过的来自突尼斯的穆斯林时，我没有想，大家冷静，两周前我和艾米谈过这个男人，他那玩意儿很大，会平息我父母的担忧。
After she first got married, I called Amy and asked how things were going. Fantastic. Marriage is great. I highly recommend it, Jeanne.
她刚结婚后，我打电话给艾米问情况怎么样。棒极了。婚姻很棒。我强烈推荐，珍妮。
Amy, the happily married woman. I like it. It seems like magic.
艾米，幸福的已婚女人。我喜欢它。这看起来像魔法。
What time is it, Amy asks.
几点了，艾米问。
3 o'clock.
3点。
You've got to be kidding me. 3 o'clock, she yells, I'm at the farmer's market waiting for [? Waleed. ?] We're supposed to be buying vegetables for a special Tunisian curry, and I've been here for an hour. An hour. Do you believe this guy? I swear to God, some people have no regard for other people. You ever notice that, she explodes.
你在开玩笑吧。3点，她大喊，我在农贸市场等[？瓦利德？]。我们本应该买蔬菜做一种特殊的突尼斯咖喱，我已经在那儿待了一个小时了。一个小时。你相信这家伙吗？我向上帝发誓，有些人对别人一点也不顾及。你注意到了吗，她爆发了。
A stretch of silence on the line.
电话里一阵沉默。
Also, he's obsessed with cleanliness. He said my apartment on Sackett Street wasn't clean.
还有，他有洁癖。他说我在萨基特街的公寓不干净。
Longer pause.
更长的停顿。
OK, scratch everything I just said. Things are fantastic. I love being married. [? Waleed ?] and I just have some, you know, cultural differences. He's very, umm, driven. He's always following up with things. Like if I say I'm going to go get my driver's license renewed, he'll ask me later how the DMV was. You know, he assumes if you say you're going to do something, you're actually going to do it. He can be very funny, Jeanne.
好吧，划掉我刚才说的一切。情况好极了。我喜欢结婚。[？瓦利德？]和我只是有一些，你知道，文化差异。他非常有，嗯，干劲。他总是跟进事情。比如如果我说我要去更新驾照，他稍后会问我车管所怎么样。你知道，他假设如果你说你要做某事，你实际上会去做。他可以非常有趣，珍妮。
That's funny, I say.
那很有趣，我说。
How can I stop my sister from blowing this, I think, without actually saying the words, don't blow this Amy? And she doesn't. Instead we've been invited to their new home for dinner. We find her building and ring the buzzer. Amy comes down to the door in a floral apron. They have curtains. Her new apartment is smoke free. Lots of sunlight, and clean bedding on the bed, which boasts a headboard and pillows of all different sizes. Her hair is combed. Apparently, they don't drink. Her bathroom seems to say, hello, I'm here for you. Look, my toilet flushes, and there's plenty of toilet paper. Should your scarf accidentally fall on the floor, there's no need to throw it away when you get home. Simply pick it up and put it back around your neck.
我怎么能阻止我姐姐搞砸这件事，我想，而不用真的说出“别搞砸了，艾米”？她没有。相反，我们被邀请到他们的新家吃晚餐。我们找到了她的楼并按了门铃。艾米穿着花围裙来开门。他们有窗帘。她的新公寓没有烟味。充足的阳光，床上铺着干净的床上用品，拥有床头板和各种尺寸的枕头。她的头发梳理整齐。显然，他们不喝酒。她的浴室似乎在说，你好，我为你而来。看，我的马桶会冲水，还有充足的卫生纸。如果你不小心把围巾掉在地上，回家时不需要扔掉它。只需捡起来重新围在脖子上。
Back in the living room, you're greeted by smells of-- is that salmon in the oven? Excuse me? Oh, Tunisian salmon, with roasted vegetables, fresh tuna croquettes, chopped Tunisian salad. You're then greeted by the chef, your new brother-in-law. He's slightly petite, very handsome with black hair and olive skin, and a smile that makes you hungry. He's [? Waleed. ?] And you, like everyone else, instantly like him.
回到客厅，迎接你的是——烤箱里那是鲑鱼吗？对不起？哦，突尼斯鲑鱼，配烤蔬菜，新鲜金枪鱼饼，切碎的突尼斯沙拉。然后迎接你的是厨师，你的新姐夫。他身材娇小，非常英俊，黑头发橄榄色皮肤，笑容让你胃口大开。他是[？瓦利德？]。而你，像其他人一样，瞬间就喜欢上了他。
Our oldest sister, Caroline, who drove in from Connecticut with her husband, Jim, and their two boys, talks of her son's summer plans. He's taking a course at the local nature preserve called CSI: New Canaan. Isn't that cute? They investigate crimes in nature.
我们的大姐卡罗琳，从康涅狄格州和她丈夫吉姆以及两个男孩开车过来，谈论她儿子的暑期计划。他在当地自然保护区上了一门叫“CSI：新迦南”的课程。那不可爱吗？他们调查自然界中的犯罪。
Jeanne Darst. She's just finishing up her first book, Fiction Ruined My Family. It has no publisher yet.
珍妮·达斯特。她刚刚完成她的第一本书，《小说毁了我的家庭》。还没有出版商。
[MUSIC- "MY SISTER" BY JULIANNA HATFIELD]
[音乐 - 朱莉安娜·哈特菲尔德的《我姐姐》]
"Act two, I Am Here to Make Frenemies."
“第二幕，我来这里不是为了交朋友。”
And now we head into the natural habitat of frenemies. The ecosystem where they are perfectly adapted, where they thrive, and are rewarded as in no other place. I'm referring to the world of television. Especially those shows where frenemies are just built into the basic DNA of the drama that unfolds.
现在我们前往“亦敌亦友”的自然栖息地。这个生态系统里他们完全适应，他们茁壮成长，并得到其他地方无法比拟的回报。我指的是电视世界。尤其是那些“亦敌亦友”被直接内置到戏剧展开的基本DNA中的节目。
And let's get past the whole Gossip Girl , The Hills , soap opera type program and go straight to reality television.
让我们跳过整个《绯闻女孩》、《好莱坞女孩》、肥皂剧类型的节目，直接进入真人秀电视节目。
Rich Juzwiak is a full-time blogger for VH1. And in his spare time, if that weren't enough, he has his own personal pop culture blog, which means that his days and nights are filled with watching, dissecting, and interviewing the people on reality TV. So he has given it a lot of thought. And last year he noticed something about the frenemy friendships that happen on reality TV.
里奇·朱兹维克是VH1的全职博主。闲暇时，如果那还不够，他有自己的个人流行文化博客，这意味着他的日日夜夜都充满了观看、剖析和采访真人秀节目中的人。所以他对此进行了很多思考。去年他注意到了真人秀节目中发生的“亦敌亦友”友谊的一些事情。
Reality TV finds its charm in repetition. Especially the shows where people compete. It's like sports. The game stays the same, and the fun is watching how different people play. And the same phrases pop up, whether it's chefs, models, or Bret Michael's groupies. Thrown under the bus. Not here for the right reasons. We could leave at any time. I want it the most. This isn't the last you've heard of me. This is not a game. We're in an alliance. You broke our alliance. Now I need a new alliance. But there is one oft repeated phrase that stands out above the rest, a battle cry that defines the philosophy underpinning all of competition reality TV.
真人秀节目在重复中寻找魅力。特别是人们竞争的节目。就像体育运动。游戏保持不变，乐趣在于观看不同的人如何比赛。相同的短语会出现，无论是厨师、模特还是布雷特·迈克尔斯的迷妹。“被扔到车下”。“不是为了正确的理由来这里”。“我们随时可以离开”。“我最想要这个”。“这不是你最后一次听到我的消息”。“这不是游戏”。“我们结成了联盟”。“你破坏了我们的联盟”。“现在我需要一个新联盟”。但有一个频繁出现的短语脱颖而出，一个定义了所有竞争类真人秀节目哲学的战斗口号。
I'm not here to make friends.
我来这里不是为了交朋友。
I mean, I don't want to be a cliche, but I'm not here to make friends.
我的意思是，我不想成为陈词滥调，但我来这里不是为了交朋友。
Those are clips from, I Know My Kid's a Star , Forever Eden , The Bachelor , Hell's Kitchen , The Pickup Artist, and Top Chef . I made this last year and posted it on Youtube, a super-cut of every iteration of, "I'm not here to make friends," that I could dig up. 55 clips, 3 minutes and 20 seconds of self-centered goodness.
这些是来自《我知道我的孩子是明星》、《永远的伊甸园》、《单身汉》、《地狱厨房》、《搭讪艺术家》和《顶级厨师》的片段。我去年制作了这个并在Youtube上发布，这是我能挖掘到的每一个“我来这里不是为了交朋友”的版本，剪辑在一起。55个片段，3分20秒的以自我为中心的盛宴。
You guys are not my friends. I'm not here to make friends with you.
你们不是我的朋友。我来这里不是为了和你们交朋友。
I'm not here to make friends.
我来这里不是为了交朋友。
When I'm watching an episode where this phrase pops up, my response is always, now it's on. Now it's a reality show, a place where an aggressive declaration of incivility is not just acceptable, it's inevitable.
当我看到出现这个短语的剧集时，我的反应总是：现在开始了。现在这是一场真人秀，一个侵略性的无礼声明不仅可接受，而且是必然的地方。
I'm not here to make friends.
我来这里不是为了交朋友。
And what makes, "I'm not here to make friends" quintessential reality TV is that it's impossible to imagine ever saying it in real life. If you're in a situation where you actually don't want to make friends, sitting for hours next to a stranger on a plane, joining a pickup game of basketball, what would you gain by announcing to everyone--
是什么让“我来这里不是为了交朋友”成为典型的真人秀电视节目，是因为无法想象在现实生活中说出它。如果你在一种你真的不想交朋友的情况下——坐在飞机上陌生人旁边几个小时，参加一场篮球斗牛——如果你宣布给每个人听，你会得到什么——
I'm not here to make friends with you guys. I could care less.
我来这里不是为了和你们交朋友。我才不在乎。
As far as I can determine, I'm not here to make friends was first said back in the pleistocene era of reality TV, the very first season of Survivor by runner-up Kelly Wiglesworth.
据我所知，“我来这里不是为了交朋友”最早是在真人秀电视的更新世时代，即《幸存者》第一季中，由亚军凯莉·威格尔斯沃思说出的。
I keep telling myself, oh, I have enough friends. I didn't come here to make friends. You know, da, da, da. And the truth is, I like these people.
我一直在告诉自己，哦，我有足够多的朋友。我来这里不是为了交朋友。你知道，等等，等等。事实是，我喜欢这些人。
Note that, "I'm not here to make friends" like reality TV itself, was in its infancy back then-- wistful, innocent, sweet even. The fangs came out and the phrase settled into dogma thanks to The Apprentice's Omarosa Manigault-Stallworth, the godmother of reality supervillains, who justified her ruthlessness with the simple brush off.
注意，那时候的“我来这里不是为了交朋友”就像真人秀本身一样，还处于起步阶段——忧郁，天真，甚至甜美。尖牙露了出来，这个短语因为《学徒》里的奥玛罗莎·马尼戈特-斯托尔沃斯而成为教条，她是真人秀超级反派的教母，她用简单的拒绝为自己的冷酷辩护。
I didn't come here to make friends. I said that from day one.
我没来这里交朋友。我从第一天就这么说了。
It snowballed from there, not here to make friends. And let's call it NHTMF for short, became the calling card of what's often the most important character on the show: the one we love to hate. The catalyst for the heaping portion of unpleasantness we're about to enjoy.
从那里开始滚雪球，不来这里交朋友。让我们简称它为NHTMF，成为了节目中通常最重要的角色的名片：我们爱恨交织的那个人。我们即将享受的这顿令人不快的大餐的催化剂。
I ain't here to make no friends.
我不来这里交任何朋友。
And enjoy it we do. It's particularly funny when the cuddlier types on reality shows are taken to task by the not here to make frienders. As though politeness is what's truly offensive in this reality world. This happened during one season of The Bachelor when one woman spat out with disgust to another contestant--
我们确实很享受。当真人秀节目中更可爱的人被那些“不是来这里交朋友”的人批评时，这特别好笑。就好像礼貌在这个真人秀世界里才是真正令人反感的。这发生在《单身汉》的一季中，当时一个女人厌恶地对另一个参赛者吐出——
Are you here to make friends? Because I'm not here to make friends?
你是来这里交朋友的吗？因为我来这里不是为了交朋友。
No, I'm not here to make friends. I'm not saying that.
不，我来这里不是为了交朋友。我不是那个意思。
Can you hear how eager the woman she's talking to is to make clear that she is definitely not here to make friends either?
你能听到她正在与之交谈的女人是多么急切地想澄清她也绝对不是来这里交朋友的吗？
As Jade Cole colorfully reminded us on America's Next Top Model --
正如杰德·科尔在《全美超模大赛》中生动提醒我们的那样——
This is a competition. This is not America's Next Top Best Friend.
这是一场比赛。这不是《全美超级好朋友》。
See also Pumpkin from Flavor of Love .
另见《爱情味道》中的南瓜。
This is Flavor of Love, not Flavor of Friendship.
这是《爱情味道》，不是《友谊味道》。
There are no friends on reality TV, only frenemies you haven't discovered yet.
真人秀节目中没有朋友，只有你还没发现的“亦敌亦友”。
Maybe we could kind of be buddies?
也许我们可以成为伙伴？
Girl, no. I'm not here to be friends, girl.
姑娘，别。我来这里不是为了交朋友，姑娘。
NHTMF works so well as a plot point, one contestant I know told a journalist she was coached by the show's producers to say it. But plenty of contestants just pull it out on their own. It's as though the savvier ones are saying, if I'm going to be spun or edited to look bad anyway, I'm going to take control of this. Because--
NHTMF作为一个情节点非常有效，我认识的一位参赛者告诉记者，她被节目的制片人教练要求说这句话。但很多参赛者自己也会把它拿出来用。就好像更精明的人在说，如果我无论如何都要被编排或剪辑成坏人，那我就要控制这件事。因为——
I'm not here to make friends, I'm here to win.
我来这里不是为了交朋友，我是为了赢。
I didn't come on the show to make friends, I came on to win.
我没来节目是为了交朋友，我是为了赢。
The thing is, they don't. Most of the people who say this phrase don't go on to win their respective shows. The winner is usually the person who flies under the radar, or whose victory makes the most uplifting story arc. Or in the rarest of instances, the person who's actually the best chef or the best designer.
问题是，他们并没有。大多数说这句话的人并没有继续赢得各自的节目。赢家通常是那个不显眼，或者其胜利制造了最振奋人心的故事线的人。或者在最罕见的情况下，是那个实际上是最好的厨师或最好的设计师的人。
Ain't no friend of mine here. I don't need no friends. I will step on the back of their neck to get to the top any time I feel it's necessary.
这里没一个是我朋友。我不需要朋友。只要我觉得有必要，我会踩着他们的脖子登上顶峰。
Though of course, there's winning, and then there's winning. If you spend any time talking to your typical reality star, you come to realize that the greatest reward of all is camera time. And the easiest way to achieve that, barring any real skill, is to tap into your id and simply unleash. And it works.
当然，赢得比赛是一回事，以某种方式胜出又是另一回事。如果你花时间和你典型的真人秀明星交谈，你会意识到最大的回报是摄像机时间。而获得这一点最简单的方法，除非有什么真正的技能，就是利用你的本我并简单地释放它。而且它确实有效。
We remember Omarosa, but can you even recall the name of the first winner of The Apprentice, much less a single sentence he uttered?
我们记得奥玛罗莎，但你甚至能想起《学徒》第一季获胜者的名字吗，更不用说他说的任何一句话了？
I'm not here to make friends.
我来这里不是为了交朋友。
Yeah, whatever. I'm not here to make friends.
是的，随便吧。我来这里不是为了交朋友。
I'm not here to make friends. I'm here to win fights.
我来这里不是为了交朋友。我是为了打赢架。
I'm not here to make friends with anybody. I'm here for Bret.
我来这里不是为了和任何人交朋友。我是为了布雷特。
I'm not here to make friends. I'm not going to apologize for how I feel. I didn't say nothing bad.
我来这里不是为了交朋友。我不会因为我的感受而道歉。我没说任何坏话。
I'm not here to make friends, and if I'm not making any enemies.
我来这里不是为了交朋友，如果我也没结交任何敌人。
Rich Juzwiak. His blog, where you can watch both of his, "I'm not here to make friends" videos is fourfourtypepad.com. That's four four, write out the word each time. F-O-U-R. fourfour.typepad.com.
里奇·朱兹维克。他的博客，你可以在那里观看他的两个“我来这里不是为了交朋友”视频，是fourfourtypepad.com。那就是four four，每次都要拼写出单词。F-O-U-R。fourfour.typepad.com。
Coming up, David Rakoff and how to make a wedding toast for people that you have never wanted to see married. And what are you doing at their wedding anyway? That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，大卫·拉科夫，关于如何为你从未想过要看到他们结婚的人致婚礼祝词。而且你到底在他们的婚礼上做什么？那就在一分钟后。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show we chose a theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Frenemies.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们选择一个主题，并为您带来关于该主题的不同类型的故事。今天的节目，《亦敌亦友》。
And if the word frenemy just seemed to show up in your life, arrive in your life a couple years ago unannounced, I think that is how pretty much everybody feels. Though, its first appearance in the world that anybody can find is all the way back in 1953. Gossip columnist, Walter Winchell, says in one of his column's, "Howz about calling the Russians our Frienemies?" Didn't catch on.
如果“frenemy”（亦敌亦友）这个词似乎是几年前才在你生活中不期而至地出现的，我想这就是大多数人的感觉。虽然，任何人能找到的它在世界上的首次出现可以追溯到1953年。八卦专栏作家沃尔特·温切尔在他的一个专栏中说：“叫俄罗斯人为我们的‘Frienemies’怎么样？”没流行起来。
Lexicographer, Erin McKean agreed to research this a little for us. She used to edit The New Oxford American Dictionary and now runs the online dictionary, Wordnik. She says the next citation of frenemy seems to be 24 years after Winchell, 1977 by the writer, Jessica Mitford.
词典编纂者艾琳·麦基恩同意为我们研究一下。她过去曾编辑《新牛津美语词典》，现在经营在线词典Wordnik。她说“frenemy”的下一个引用似乎是在温切尔之后24年，即1977年，由作家杰西卡·米特福德所引用。
When she was talking about her sister and her sister's frenemy, and said they played together constantly and all the time disliking each other heartily.
当她谈到她的姐姐和她姐姐的“亦敌亦友”时，说她们经常一起玩，但一直衷心地不喜欢对方。
Mitford said that she and her sisters used the words as kids and they thought they made it up. It still doesn't catch on. The next citation is 15 years after that, 1992, in a book of word games. And that author also thinks that she is inventing the word. It's not until the late 1990s that it shows up and the people using the word seem to believe that any other people have ever used it before them. It's in a hit song by the New Radicals, "You Get What You Give" in 1998.
米特福德说她和她的姐妹们小时候用过这个词，她们以为是自己编的。它仍然没有流行起来。下一次引用是15年后，1992年，在一本文字游戏书中。那位作者也认为她是发明了这个词。直到1990年代末，它才出现，而且使用这个词的人似乎认为在他们之前没有任何其他人用过它。它出现在新激进乐队1998年的热门歌曲《You Get What You Give》中。
And then it was on Sex and the City in 2000, late 2000.
然后它在2000年出现在《欲望都市》中，2000年底。
Is that the turning point?
那是转折点吗？
I think so.
我想是的。
After that, she says, it starts showing up all over the place. You get the executive editor of The New York Times , Bill Keller, declaring that Google is one of those companies The New York Times quote, "refers to as a frenemy," end quote.
在那之后，她说，它开始出现在各个地方。《纽约时报》执行主编比尔·凯勒宣布谷歌是《纽约时报》引述的“被称为frenemy的公司之一”，引述结束。
In 2008, it's put into the online Oxford English Dictionary .
2008年，它被收入在线《牛津英语词典》。
In 2009-- just two months ago-- it enters Merriam-Webster's dictionary. But Erin McKean found it in one place much, much more than any other: young adult novels, targeted at teen girls, starting at around 2006.
2009年——就在两个月前——它进入了韦氏词典。但艾琳·麦基恩在年轻成人小说中发现它的频率远远高于其他任何地方，这些小说针对的是少女，大约从2006年开始。
But a lot of these words are just forcing their way to the surface of English. They just need to be made. And I think frenemy is a word like that.
但很多这些词只是强行浮出英语表面。它们只是需要被创造出来。我想“frenemy”就是一个那样的词。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. I mean, well, think about it. So the sounds fit together really well. You know, friend and enemy. They have a matching sound that you can blend together. So it's a blend word. And people love the juxtaposition of two opposites.
是的。我的意思是，嗯，考虑一下。所以声音非常吻合。你知道，friend（朋友）和enemy（敌人）。它们有一个可以混合在一起的匹配声音。所以这是一个混合词。人们喜欢两个对立面的并置。
Wait, are there other words like this where they sound alike and then they get smashed together into one word?
等等，有其他像这样的词吗，它们听起来相似，然后被合并成一个词？
Oh, it happens like all the time. Like guesstimate. And that's from 1936.
哦，经常发生。比如“guesstimate”（猜测估计）。那是1936年的。
Do you have another?
你有另一个吗？
I love this one, and people say this one all the time with a little thrill of thinking they're the first person ever to say it. You know, that someone is entering their anecdotage.
我喜欢这一个，人们总是带着一种以为自己是第一个说出来的人的微小快感说这个词。你知道，有人进入了他们的“anecdotage”（逸事期）。
Oh, I've never heard that. So it's like you get old and then you start telling your anecdotes, and that's it?
哦，我从没听说过。所以就像你变老了，然后你开始讲述你的逸事，就是这样？
Right. And I think the essential part is you start telling the same anecdotes over and over again.
对。我认为关键部分是你开始反复讲述相同的逸事。
Right. You got another?
对。你还有吗？
Lots of people say that they are the first person to create the word linner.
很多人说他们是第一个创造“linner”这个词的人。
Linner?
Linner？
Linner is that meal you must have between lunch and dinner.
Linner就是你必须在午餐和晚餐之间吃的那顿饭。
That just makes me feel mad at somebody hearing that. You're like, oh for God's sake, wipe that look off your face.
听到这个只会让我对某人生气。你会觉得，哦，看在上帝的份上，把你脸上那种表情收起来。
Right. And a lot of people who come and talk to lexicographers think they're being really clever when they use the word slanguage. So, slang plus language.
对。很多去和词典编纂者交谈的人在使用“slanguage”（俚语）这个词时认为自己非常聪明。即slang（俚语）加language（语言）。
But you do not find that clever?
但你觉得那不聪明？
I just don't use it very much myself.
我自己不经常用它。
Does the fact that there's a word for this phenomenon, frenemy, indicate that it's a common thing to happen in the world?
有一个词来形容这种现象——“亦敌亦友”——是否表明它在世界上是一种普遍的事情？
Oh, no. Because there are words for all sorts of crazy and unusual things that are fairly rare. I mean there are lots of things that we talk about that we don't have single words for in English. When we don't have a single word for something in English that we think we should have a word for, it's called a lexical gap.
哦，不。因为有各种疯狂和不寻常事情的词，它们相当罕见。我的意思是，有很多我们谈论的事情，我们在英语中没有单一的词。当我们在英语中对某事没有单一的词，而我们认为我们应该有一个词时，它被称为“词汇缺口”。
Well, like what's an example of that?
嗯，比如那有什么例子？
Pretty much the most famous example of a lexical gap is that we have a word for people who've lost their parents. You know, we call them orphans. But we don't have a single word for parents who have lost a child. So there are lots of people who have made suggestions. None of which I can remember right now because none of them have stuck.
词汇缺口最著名的例子几乎是，我们有失去父母的人的词。你知道，我们叫他们孤儿。但我们没有失去孩子的父母的单一词。所以很多人提出了建议。我目前一个也记不住，因为没有一个流传下来。
Right. That sounds like some sad contest on public radio on the weekend where they'd have people write in to make up that word.
对。那听起来像周末公共广播上的某种悲伤竞赛，他们会让人们写信来编造那个词。
Right.
对。
It's worth noting that while Erin found tons of citations referring to girl frenemies, she only found a couple in which men were each other's frenemies. NASCAR driver, Dale Earnhardt, is described in a book as being frenemies with Michael Waltrip on his team.
值得注意的是，虽然艾琳发现了大量指代女性“亦敌亦友”的引文，但她只发现了几例男性互为“亦敌亦友”的情况。纳斯卡赛车手戴尔·恩哈特在书中被描述为与他车队的迈克尔·沃尔特普是“亦敌亦友”。
And the most random citation? It linked to the word with Hindu scripture from two millennia ago.
而最随机的引用呢？它与两千年前的印度教经文中的词联系在一起。
Someone was trying to refer to the Bhagavad Gita, and there's some line in it that says, "Self is the friend of self. Self is the enemy of self." And then they say, so you can talk about yourself as your frenemy. So there's like this total abrupt shift of tone from self is the friend of self to self is your frenemy.
有人试图引用《薄伽梵歌》，里面有一行说：“自我即自我的朋友。自我即自我的敌人。”然后他们说，所以你可以把你自己称为你自己的“亦敌亦友”。所以从“自我即自我的朋友”到“自我即你的亦敌亦友”，语气有一个完全突然的转变。
Self is your frenemy. That sentence just proves that while we have all come to learn the word frenemy sometime during the last decade, any sentence with the word frenemy is probably not a sentence you want to try to get profound with. Frenemy's here. It's on the scene. It's here to stay as a word. But it is still not ready for the heavy lifting.
自我即你的“亦敌亦友”。这句话刚好证明了，虽然我们在过去十年里都学会了“frenemy”这个词，但任何带有“frenemy”这个词的句子可能都不是你想试图变得深奥的句子。“亦敌亦友”就在这里。它在现场。它作为词会留下来。但它还没准备好承担繁重的工作。
"Act three, Speak Now or Forever Hold Your Peace."
“第三幕，现在说出来，否则永远保持沉默”。
Being not friend friends can get you into some very confusing situations. Take this example from David Rakoff.
不是朋友的朋友关系会让你陷入一些非常令人困惑的情况。以大卫·拉科夫的这个例子为例。
Nathan at one of the outlying tables, his feet tangled up in the disc jockey's cables, surveyed the room as unseen as a ghost, while he mulled over what he might say for his toast. That the couple had asked him for this benediction seemed at odds with them parking him here by the kitchen. That he'd shown up at all was still a surprise. And not just to him, it was there in the eyes of the guests who had seen a mirage and drew near, and then covered their shock with a, "Nathan, you're here." And then, silence. They had nothing to say beyond that. A few of the braver souls lingered to chat. They all knew it was neither a secret nor a mystery that he and the couple had quite an odd history.
内森在偏远的一张桌子旁，脚缠在唱片骑师的电缆里，像个幽灵一样默默地俯瞰房间，同时他思考着他可能会为他的祝酒词说些什么。这对夫妻让他做这个祈福似乎与他们把他停在厨房旁边相矛盾。他居然出现了本身就是一个惊喜。不仅仅对他而言，在那些看到海市蜃楼并靠近的客人的眼里，这种惊讶都在那里，然后他们用一句“内森，你在这儿”掩盖了他们的震惊。然后，沉默。除了那句话，他们无话可说。几个勇敢的灵魂留下来聊天。他们都知道，他和这对夫妻有着非常奇怪的历史，这既不是秘密也不是谜团。
Their bonds were a tangle of friendship and sex. Josh, his best pal once, and Patty, his ex.
他们的纽带是友谊和性的纠葛。乔什，他曾经最好的伙伴，和帕蒂，他的前任。
For a while he could barely go out in the city without being a punchline or object of pity. Poor Nathan had virtually become his new name, and so he showed up just to show he was game. Though his invite was late, a forgotten addendum. For Nate there could be no more clear referendum that he need but endure through this evening. And then, he would likely not see Josh and Patty again.
有一段时间，他几乎不能在城市里外出而不成为笑柄或怜悯的对象。“可怜的内森”几乎成了他的新名字，所以他出现只是为了证明他很有种。虽然他的邀请很晚，是一个被遗忘的附录。对内特来说，再没有比这更明确的公投了，他只需要忍受今晚。然后，他很可能再也不会见到乔什和帕蒂了。
Josh's sister was speaking, a princess in peach. Nathan dug in his pocket to study his speech. He had poured over Bartlett's for couplets to filch. He'd stayed up until 3:00, still came up with zilch.
乔什的姐姐正在发言，一个桃色礼服的公主。内森伸手进口袋研究他的演讲。他曾为了一些可以偷来的对联钻研《巴特莱特语录》。他熬到3点，依然一无所获。
Except for instructions he'd underscored twice. Just two words in length, and those words were, be nice. Too often he thought our emotions betray us and reason departs once were up on the dais. He'd witnessed uncomfortable moments where others had lost their way quickly, where sisters and brothers had gotten too prickly, and peppered their babbling with stories of benders or lesbian dabbling, or spot on impressions of mothers-in-law Which true, Nathan thought, always garnered guffaws. But the price seemed too high, with the laugh seldom cloaking. Hostility masquerading as joking.
除了他下划线两次的指示。只有两个字长，那些字是，“要友善”。他认为太频繁了，我们的情绪会背叛我们，一旦我们站在讲台上，理智就会离去。他目睹过尴尬的时刻，其他人迅速迷失了方向，姐妹和兄弟变得太带刺，在他们的喋喋不休中穿插着狂欢或女同性恋尝试的故事，或者对婆婆惟妙惟肖的模仿。虽然内森认为，这些总是赢得了哄堂大笑。但代价似乎太高了，笑声很少掩盖敌意。敌意伪装成玩笑。
No, he'd swallow his rage and he'd bank all his fire. He knew that in his case the bar was set higher. Folks were just waiting for him to erupt. They'd be hungry for blood even though they had supped. They'd want tears, or some other unsightly reaction, and Nathan would not give them that satisfaction. Though Patty a harlot and Josh was a lout, at least Nathan knew what he'd not talk about.
不，他会咽下他的愤怒，他会把所有的火药味存起来。他知道就他的情况而言，标准被设置得更高。人们只是在等他爆发。即使他们已经吃过晚餐，他们也会渴求血腥。他们会想要眼泪，或者其他难看的反应，内森不会给他们那种满足感。虽然帕蒂是个荡妇，乔什是个混蛋，至少内森知道他不会谈论什么。
I won't wish them divorce, that they wither and sicken, or tonight that they choke on their salmon or chicken. I won't mention that time when the cottage lost power in that storm on the Cape and they left for an hour. And they thought it was just the cleverest ruse to pretend it took that long to switch out the fuse. Or that time Josh advised me with so much insistence that I should grant Patty a little more distance. That the worst I could do was to hamper and crowd her. That if Patty felt stifled she'd just take a powder. That a plant needs its space just as much as its water.
我不会祝愿他们离婚，让他们枯萎和生病，或者今晚让他们被鲑鱼或鸡肉噎死。我不会提到那次斗篷的暴风雨中，小屋断电，他们离开了一个小时。他们以为这是一个最聪明的诡计，假装花了那么久才换保险丝。或者那次乔什如此坚持地建议我，我应该给帕蒂多一点距离。我能做的最糟的事就是阻碍和拥挤她。如果帕蒂感到窒息，她只会溜走。植物需要空间就像它需要水一样。
And I shouldn't give Patty that ring that I'd bought her. Which in retrospect, only elicits a, gosh, I hardly deserved a friend like you, Josh.
我不应该给我给她买的那枚戒指。回想起来，这只会引起一句，“天哪，我几乎不配拥有你这样的朋友，乔什。”
No, I won't spill those beans, or make myself foolish, to satisfy appetites venal and ghoulish. I will not be the blot on this hellish affair. And with that, Nathan pushed out and rose from his chair. And just by the tapping of knife against crystal, all eyes turned his way, like he'd fired off a pistol.
不，我不会泄露那些秘密，或让自己显得愚蠢，去满足那些贪婪和食尸鬼般的胃口。我不会成为这件地狱般事情上的污点。随之，内森推开椅子站了起来。仅凭刀子敲击水晶的声音，所有人的目光都转向了他，就像他开了一枪。
Joshua, Patricia, dear family and friends, a few words, if you will, before everything ends.
乔舒亚，帕特里夏，亲爱的家人和朋友们，在一切结束前，如果可以，请让我说几句话。
You've promised to honor, to love and obey. We've quaffed our champagne and been cleansed by sorbet, all in endorsement of your hers-and-his-dom. So now let me add my two cents' worth of wisdom.
你们承诺要尊重、爱和服从。我们已经喝了香槟，被雪酪洗涤了，这一切都是为了支持你们的“她和他的”结合。所以现在让我加上我两分钱的智慧。
I was racking my brain sitting here at this table until I remembered this suitable fable that gets at a truth, though it may well distort us. So here with the tale of the scorpion and tortoise.
我坐在桌前绞尽脑汁，直到我想起这个合适的寓言，它触及了一个真理，尽管它很可能会扭曲我们。所以，讲讲蝎子和乌龟的故事吧。
The scorpion was hamstrung, his tail all aquiver, just how would he manage to get cross the river? The water's so deep, he observed with a sigh, which pricked at the ears of the tortoise nearby.
蝎子被困住了，尾巴颤抖着，他该怎么过河呢？水太深了，他叹了口气，这刺痛了附近乌龟的耳朵。
Well, why don't you swim, asked the slow-moving fellow. Unless you're afraid, I mean, what are you, yellow?
嗯，你为什么不游呢，那个移动缓慢的家伙问。除非你害怕，我的意思是，你怎么了，你是胆小鬼吗？
It isn't a matter of fear or of whim, said the scorpion, but that I don't know how to swim.
这不是害怕或冲动的问题，蝎子说，而是因为我根本不会游泳。
Ah, forgive me, I didn't mean to be glib when I said that. I figured you were an amphibian.
啊，原谅我，我这么说并不是要轻浮。我还以为你是两栖动物呢。
No offense taken, the scorpion replied. But how bout you help me to reach the far side? You swim like a dream and you have what I lack. Let's say you take me across on your back.
没冒犯，蝎子回答。但你帮我到达对岸怎么样？你游起来像梦一样，你拥有我所缺乏的东西。不如你背我过去。
I'm really not sure that's the best thing to do, said the tortoise, now that I see that it's you. You've a less than ideal reputation preceding. There's talk of your victims all poisoned and bleeding. You're the scorpion, and how can I say this, but well, I just don't feel safe with you riding my shell.
我真的不确定那是最好的做法，乌龟说，既然我知道是你。你有一个不太理想的名声。有关于你的受害者被毒死和流血的传闻。你是蝎子，我该怎么说呢，嗯，我只是觉得你坐在我的壳上不安全。
The scorpion replied, what would killing you prove? We'd both drown. So tell me, how would that behoove me to basically die at my very own hand, when all I desire is to be on dry land?
蝎子回答，杀死你会证明什么？我们都会淹死。所以告诉我，对我来说，死在自己手里怎么会有好处呢，当我的渴望只是站在干地上？
The tortoise considered the scorpion's defense. When he gave it some thought, it made perfect sense. The niggling voice in his mind he ignored, and he swam to the bank and called out, climb aboard.
乌龟考虑了蝎子的辩护。当他想了想，那说得完全有道理。他忽略了脑海中微小的声音，他游向岸边大喊，上来吧。
But just a few moments from when they set sail, the scorpion lashed out with his venomous tail. The tortoise, too late, understood that he'd blundered when he felt his flesh stabbed and his carapace sundered. As he fought for his life he said, tell me why you have done this for now we will surely both die?
但离他们启航仅几分钟，蝎子就用他的毒尾刺了出去。乌龟，太迟了，才明白他搞砸了，当他感觉到自己的肉被刺穿，甲壳碎裂。当他为生命而战时，他说，告诉我你为什么要这样做，因为现在我们肯定都会死？
I don't know, cried the scorpion. You never should trust a creature like me because poison I must. I'd claim some remorse or at least some compunction, but I just can't help it, my form is my function. You thought I'd behave like my cousin the crab, but unlike him it is but my nature to stab.
我不知道，蝎子哭了。你永远不应该信任像我这样的生物，因为毒药是我必须做的。我会声称有一些悔恨，或者至少是一些内疚，但我只是忍不住，我的形式就是我的功能。你以为我会表现得像我的表亲螃蟹一样，但不像他，刺人是我的天性。
The tortoise expired with one final quiver, and then both of them sank, swallowed up by the river.
乌龟在最后一次颤抖中去世了，然后他们俩都沉下去了，被河流吞没。
The tortoise was wrong to ignore all his doubts, because in the end, friends, our natures will out.
乌龟忽略所有的怀疑是错误的，因为最后，朋友们，我们的天性会暴露无遗。
Nathan paused, cleared his throat, took a sip of his drink. He needed these extra few seconds to think. The room had gone frosty, the tension was growing. Folks wondered precisely where Nathan was going. The prospects of skirting fiasco seemed dim, but what he said next surprised even him.
内森停顿，清了清嗓子，喝了一口饮料。他需要这额外的几秒钟来思考。房间变冷了，紧张局势在加剧。人们想知道内森到底要去哪里。避免惨败的前景似乎很渺茫，但他接下来说的话连他自己都感到惊讶。
So what can we learn from their watery ends? Is there some lesson on how to be friends? I think what it means is that central to living, a life that is good is a life that's forgiving. We're creatures of contact. Regardless of whether we kiss or we wound, still we must come together.
那么我们能从他们水下的结局学到什么呢？关于如何交朋友有什么教训吗？我认为这意味着，对生活至关重要的一点是，美好的一生就是宽恕的一生。我们是接触的生物。无论我们是接吻还是伤害，我们仍然必须聚在一起。
Though it may spell destruction, we still ask for more, since it beats staying dry, but so lonely on shore. So we make ourselves open, while knowing full well it's essentially saying, please, come pierce my shell.
尽管它可能意味着毁灭，我们仍然会要求更多，因为它总比待在干地上要好，但孤单地待在岸上。所以我们让自己敞开，尽管完全知道这本质上是在说，请，来刺穿我的壳吧。
Silence doesn't paint the depth of quiet in that room. There was no clinking stemware toasting to the bride or groom. You could have heard a petal as it landed on the floor. And in that stillness Nathan turned and walked right out the door.
沉默无法描绘那个房间里安静的深度。没有碰撞的杯脚声为新娘或新郎祝酒。你可以听到花瓣落在地上的声音。在那片宁静中，内森转身走了出门。
David Rakoff is the author of several books, most recently, Don't Get Too Comfortable .
大卫·拉科夫是几本书的作者，最近的一本是《别太舒适》。
"Act four, The Case of the Long Lost Frenemy."
“第四幕，失踪的‘亦敌亦友’案”。
Did you ever get into one of those situations with somebody where you can't really tell, you actually can't tell, wait, are we friends, are we not friends? What do you want from me exactly?
你有没有遇到过那种和某人在一起的情况，你真的分不清，真的分不清，等等，我们是朋友，我们不是朋友吗？你到底想要我怎样？
Elle Smith found herself in that situation with a woman that here on the radio we're calling Jennifer, who Elle Smith knew in high school. And who got in touch with Elle Smith out of the blue by email. And then they slowly began an email correspondence.
艾尔·史密斯在一位我们在电台里称之为詹妮弗的女人身上遇到了这种情况，艾尔·史密斯在高中时认识她。她突然通过电子邮件与艾尔·史密斯取得了联系。然后他们慢慢开始了电子邮件交流。
I hadn't heard anything from her in over 35 years. Our parting had been so monumentally final and kind of dramatic.
我有超过35年没听到她的任何消息了。我们的分手非常具有纪念意义，最终且有点戏剧性。
And you say monumental, monumental and bad it sounds like?
你说纪念意义，纪念意义且糟糕，听起来是这样？
Monumental and bad, yeah. Absolutely. We'd had this really, really intense friendship. Very, very tight, told each other everything, at sort of the white hot phase of adolescence. And then it ended when she basically wrote this very formal letter disowning me, saying that our friendship was over, she would have nothing to do further with me. And that was the end.
纪念意义且糟糕，是的。绝对是。我们有过这种非常、非常强烈的友谊。非常、非常紧密，在青春期的那种白热化阶段，告诉对方一切。然后它结束了，当时她基本上写了这封非常正式的信与我断绝关系，说我们的友谊结束了，她以后会和我没有任何关系。那是终点。
And so it was just really dissonant to get this chirpy, hey you, kind of email.
所以收到这种活泼的，“嘿，你”之类的电子邮件真的很不和谐。
You forwarded a couple of these emails and the very first one from her, she writes in her email, "Is it too strange to write and catch up? Is that you, [? Elpie?" ?]
你转发了几封这些邮件，她写的第一封邮件里写着，“写信来叙旧太奇怪了吗？那是你吗，[？埃尔皮？]？”
Yes.
是的。
"Cheers." And then she signs her name.
“干杯。”然后她签上了她的名字。
Yes. And it was weird and strange. So she called me by my childhood nickname, which I haven't heard or seen in decades. So that was just kind of like one of those things where she was googling around and saw that my name had come up. And this correspondence sort of unfolds over several months. And so I keep waiting for the other shoe to drop.
是的。而且这很奇怪、很陌生。所以她叫了我儿时的昵称，我几十年没听到或看到过了。所以这就像她四处搜索谷歌，看到我的名字出现了之类的东西之一。这种通信大约展开了几个月。所以我一直等着另一只鞋掉下来。
Oh, because after this first initial exchange of two emails, nobody brings it up. Nobody brings up, oh, by the way, about that letter you wrote me cutting me off forever. That doesn't come up?
哦，因为在第一次交换了两封邮件后，没人提起它。没人提起，哦，顺便问一下，关于你写给我的那封彻底切断我关系的信。那没被提起？
Not directly. At first I thought, well, she's just pretending not to remember and she just wants us to be all nice nice. And then as things kind of continued I realized, oh, she has absolutely and genuinely no recollection. There's something else going on here.
没有直接提起。起初我想，嗯，她只是假装不记得，她只是想让我们都好好的。然后随着事情持续进行，我意识到，哦，她绝对是真的没有任何记忆。这其中发生了别的事情。
And so what happened as you corresponded more?
所以随着你们通信增多，发生了什么？
So as we correspond, we start talking about our families a little bit. She has daughters, and she talks about what her daughters are doing. And what becomes very striking is that one of her daughters, she's very, very serious about her music, like sort of a talented, obsessive musician. This is exactly where I was when I was at exactly this age. So this daughter is 14 years old. There's this very, very strong parallel between what her daughter's like now and what I was like then. Including, and this is where things started to get kind of crazy, this very, very close relationship between her daughter and her music-- the daughter's music teacher.
所以随着我们通信，我们开始稍微谈论我们的家庭。她有女儿，她谈论她的女儿在做什么。而变得非常引人注目的是，她的一个女儿，她对她的音乐非常、非常认真，就像那种有天赋、执着的音乐家。这正是我在完全这个年龄时所处的状态。所以这个女儿14岁。她女儿现在是什么样和我当时是什么样之间有非常、非常强烈的平行。包括，这就是事情开始变得有点疯狂的地方，她的女儿和她的音乐——女儿的音乐老师之间那种非常、非常亲密的关系。
Sort of the hair stood up on the back of my neck, kind of when she started talking about it. An older male, very charismatic, and sort of reading between the lines I could tell you that Jennifer was somewhat uneasy with this relationship. But as she expressed it, my daughter's privacy is so very precious to me and I would never dream of interfering.
当她开始谈论它时，我的后颈汗毛似乎竖了起来。一个年长的男性，非常有魅力，我从字里行间能看出詹妮弗对这种关系有些不安。但正如她表达的那样，“我女儿的隐私对我来说非常珍贵，我绝不会梦想干涉。”
Did the daughter have a crush on the teacher?
那个女儿对老师有迷恋吗？
Yes. So the daughter seemed to be, in Jennifer's view, almost too close to the music teacher. She was having private lessons with him, and apparently also had a very, very intense internet relationship with him. So they were corresponding over the phone and corresponding over the internet, and then also having private lessons. And I could smell it. I know the sort of the danger signs in that kind of relationship.
是的。所以在詹妮弗看来，女儿似乎和音乐老师走得太近了。她和他上私人课，显然也和他有非常、非常强烈的互联网关系。所以他们通过电话通信，通过互联网通信，然后还上私人课。我能闻到它。我知道那种关系中的危险信号。
And talk about your own experience when it came to that kind of thing.
谈谈你自己在这方面经历的事情。
OK, so when I was a kid I had a difficult family situation, and I was, I think, at the same age, really looking for acceptance, and authority figures were very attractive to me. And I respected my teachers and just loved them. And then what happened to me was that right at that point I came into contact with a music teacher who a normal person would not violate that kind of relationship, but this guy was a complete predator. And I was molested and raped at the age of 13 by this guy. Totally traumatized, huge fallout from it. Destroyed my life in certain ways for a long time. Took me a long, long time to kind of put it together from that.
好吧，所以当我还是个孩子时，我有一个困难的家庭情况，我想，在同样的年龄，我真的很寻求接受，权威人物对我很有吸引力。我尊重我的老师，只是爱他们。然后发生在我身上的是，就在那个时候，我接触到了一位音乐老师，一个正常人不会侵犯那种关系，但这个家伙是一个彻头彻尾的捕食者。那个家伙在13岁时猥亵并强奸了我。彻底遭受创伤，巨大的后果。在某种程度上摧毁了我的生活很长一段时间。花了我很长、很长的时间才从那件事中走出来。
And Jennifer was one of the, I think, two people that I told. On the one hand, we were in this completely parallel situation where we both had crushes on these teachers. And then suddenly--
詹妮弗是我想我告诉过的两个人之一。一方面，我们处在完全平行的境地，我们俩都对这些老师有迷恋。然后突然——
Oh, she also at that time when you're in high school, she had a crush on a teacher?
哦，她当时在高中时也对老师有迷恋？
Yes, huge crush on her teacher. And we would get together and giggle and talk about how wonderful these teachers were, and how fascinating everything that they did was, and all this kind of stuff. And then we got to this moment where, in my instance, this guy just completely took it, and it was like I fell off a cliff with it. Because he was a pedophile. And whereas her teacher was-- it continued on in this kind of storybook teenagery, giggly thing. So I was kind of off on my own in this whole different, horrible world. And Jennifer was still in her childhood in a sense.
是的，对她的老师有巨大的迷恋。我们会聚在一起咯咯笑，谈论这些老师有多棒，他们所做的一切有多迷人，诸如此类。然后我们到了那个时刻，在我的情况下，这个家伙完全占有了它，就像我从悬崖上掉下来一样。因为他是个恋童癖。而她的老师却是——它以那种故事书般的青春期、咯咯笑的事情持续下去。所以我以那种完全不同、可怕的世界独自离开了。而詹妮弗在某种意义上还停留在她的童年中。
And then eventually did your parents find out and authorities find out, and was action taken against this guy?
最后你的父母发现了吗，当局发现了吗，有针对那个家伙采取行动吗？
No, no action was ever taken. My family-- I tried approaching my parents about it. And they just weren't that interested. And, in fact, their explicit position was, some things really ought to be private. And so at that point I kind of realized, oh.
没有，没采取任何行动。我的家庭——我尝试向父母接近这件事。他们并不那么感兴趣。事实上，他们的明确立场是，“有些事情真的应该私密。”所以在那一点上，我意识到，哦。
They're not going to be a help?
他们不会提供帮助？
They're not going to be a help. And certainly, they're not going to call in any kind of authority.
他们不会提供帮助。当然，他们也不会叫来任何当局。
So you told Jennifer and one other friend?
所以你告诉了詹妮弗和另一个朋友？
Yeah. And Jennifer's family was extremely loving in this situation. I don't think she ever actually told them what had happened to me, but it was clear that I was really troubled, and really depressed, and completely kind of feral. And so they became like another family to me. So I would go and I would stay with them. And I think it was a way of kind of pretending that my childhood also was continuing. And they really kind of were a refuge for me during the very worst period.
是的。詹妮弗的家庭在这种情况下极其充满爱。我不认为她真的告诉过他们发生在我身上的事，但很清楚我真的很困扰，真的很沮丧，完全就像野人一样。所以他们变得像我的另一个家庭。所以我经常去和他们待在一起。我想这是一种假装我的童年也在持续的方式。在最糟糕的时期，他们确实像我的避难所。
And you said before that at some point she cut you off. Was that part of this?
你说过之前在某个点她切断了你。那是这的一部分吗？
Yeah, so kind of about six to eight months after this guy raped me, Jennifer and this other friend wrote this letter basically saying, you're not one of us anymore. We reject you, and we don't want to have anything to do with you further.
是的，在这个家伙强奸我大约六到八个月后，詹妮弗和那个朋友写了这封信，基本上说：“你不再是我们中的一员了。我们拒绝你，我们不想以后和你再有任何关系。”
Wait, wait, wait. Was there a problem with you that you somehow seemed different than them now that you had this experience, or were they blaming you for what had happened? Were they saying that you had like bad character that this happened?
等等，等等，等等。是因为你有问题，你看起来以某种方式和她们不同了，既然你有了这个经历，还是她们在责怪你发生了这种事？她们是在说你有坏品格才导致这种情况吗？
I think a bit of both. Maybe in terms of Jennifer's perspective, this could have been her. So I think on some level what she was doing was saying, I'm not you and you're not me.
我想两者皆有。也许在詹妮弗的角度，这本来也可能是她。所以我认为在某种程度上，她所做的是说，“我不是你，你不是我。”
But the irony is that-- and this comes out in these emails 35 years later. In fact, she went on to marry her high school teacher.
但讽刺的是——这在35年后的这些邮件中显露出来。事实上，她后来嫁给了她的高中老师。
Wait, to marry that same teacher?
等等，嫁给同一个老师？
Not the same one, a different one. Literally within two years she marries another teacher. And what's interesting is that in the emails she points to that as being a reason why we quote, "lost touch." So she said, oh, I lost touch with so many of my friends as a result of that relationship. And I'm thinking, huh, OK. Well, that's weird.
不是同一个，不同的一个。真的是在两年内她嫁给了另一个老师。而有趣的是，在邮件中她指出那是我们引述“失去联系”的原因。所以她说，哦，因为那种关系我与这么多朋友失去了联系。而我想，嗯，好吧。嗯，那很奇怪。
Then she divorces him and marries-- it sounds like a really, really nice guy. And that's the guy with whom she has the kids.
然后她和他离婚并嫁给了——听起来是一个真的、真的很好的人。那正是她有了孩子的那个家伙。
And so this is your history with her, and then you find yourself 35 years later emailing with her about her daughter and her daughter's crush on her teacher. And she doesn't seem to remember any of that?
所以这就是你和她的历史，然后你发现35年后你和她发邮件谈论她的女儿和她女儿对老师的迷恋。她似乎不记得那其中的任何事？
None of it. Not a single detail. Yeah. And then when it became clear that her daughter was like in this really, really perilous situation, and recognizing that Jennifer wasn't seeing the train coming on the tracks. At that point, I said, look, I know that you respect your daughter's privacy, but this doesn't sound right, and I think you ought to contact the authorities.
一点也不。没一个细节。是的。然后当很明显她的女儿处于这种真的、真的危险的情况时，并且意识到詹妮弗没有看到铁轨上开来的火车。在那一点上，我说：“看，我知道你尊重你女儿的隐私，但这听起来不对，我认为你应该联系当局。”
And did she?
她联系了吗？
She did. And what was kind of interesting about it was that there was a long kind of lull. So there are about two weeks where there's like complete radio silence between us. And I'm thinking to myself, oh I pushed too hard. Because I thought about it very, very carefully before I suggested that to her. Because I thought, am I pushing somebody to violate their relationship with their child? Am I so blinded by my own personal history that this, in fact, is perfectly fine as a relationship? Blah, blah, blah. And then I get this email from her, and I was totally blown away because she just went in and took care of business in a really impressive way.
她联系了。关于它有点有趣的是，有一段长时间的停顿。所以大约有两周我们之间完全静默。我在心里想，哦，我推得太狠了。因为在向她建议之前，我非常、非常仔细地考虑过它。因为我想，我是在推动某人违反与孩子的关系吗？我是否因为自己的个人历史而盲目，这实际上是一种完全没问题的关系？等等，等等。然后我收到了她的邮件，我被彻底震撼了，因为她直接进入并以一种真的令人印象深刻的方式处理了这件事。
So she got in touch with a counselor, the counselor put her in touch with the police. The police moved on this. The daughter's cell phone and computer were seized. This guy was known to the police.
所以她联系了一位辅导员，辅导员让她与警方联系。警方采取了行动。女儿的手机和电脑被扣押。那个家伙被警方所知。
Known to the police like he had had previous incidents?
被警方所知，就像他有之前的事件一样？
Yeah. I really felt like I had inadvertently participated in this important salvation for this young girl that I didn't know. So it was dramatic and entirely fabulous as an outcome.
是的。我真的觉得我无意中参与了对这个我不认识的年轻女孩的重要拯救。所以结果是戏剧性且完全极好的。
And after all that happened, did she remember or acknowledge any of these things from your past?
在那一切发生后，她记得或承认过你过去的一点事吗？
Nothing. Not a single peep. It ended kind of like it began with, gee, everything's great now. I'm so glad I did that. And thanks for pushing me on that. And everything's fine now. And have a good Thanksgiving, basically was how it ended. And never heard from her since. That was it. That was our last contact.
什么都没有。一点反应都没有。它结束得就像它开始时一样，哇，一切现在好极了。我很高兴我这么做了。谢谢你在这件事上推动我。现在一切都好了。基本就以“感恩节快乐”结束了。从那以后再也没听到她的消息。就是那样。那是我们的最后一次联系。
How do you know that she didn't remember? What convinced you of that?
你怎么知道她不记得？是什么让你确信这一点？
I think knowing her family. There was no room in that family for this kind of thing. I remember getting her chirpy emails and thinking, sheesh, she has totally become her mother, the world's most repressed happy person. Yeah, I do think that she genuinely in her conscious mind did not remember. But I also think that the timing speaks to a totally different logic. So I think that some part of her knew it.
我想了解她的家庭。那个家庭里没有这种事的空间。我记得收到她那些活泼的邮件，心想，啧，她完全变成了她妈妈，世界上最压抑的快乐的人。是的，我确实认为她在意识层面上是真的不记得了。但我还认为时间点说明了完全不同的逻辑。所以我认为她的某部分知道它。
In one of the emails she mentions how strange that I should reach out to you at such a critical time. She's very smart. She knew that there was some link between our history and the timing. And I think in some sense she was sort of subconsciously counting on my doing something that she couldn't do.
在其中一封邮件中，她提到，在如此关键的时刻我应该联系你真是太奇怪了。她很聪明。她知道我们的历史和时间点之间有某种联系。我想在某种意义上，她潜意识里指望我去做她无法做到的事情。
God, people do so many things without knowing that they're doing them.
天哪，人们在不知道自己在做这些事的情况下做了这么多事情。
Yes. There was like one person in the entire universe she knew that she could talk to about it who would get her to do the right thing. And to be able to actually do something about it. I feel like it resolved something for me, no question.
是的。整个宇宙中只有一个人她知道她可以与之谈论这件事，会让她做正确的事情。并能够实际对此采取行动。我觉得它解决了我的一些事，毫无疑问。
Well, I understand. It's funny because I feel like it resolves each of the things that had been so disturbing. It resolved the rift between you and her, which seems sort of horrible. And then it lets you fix the situation for a girl who's sort of a stand-in for you at the same age as you were.
嗯，我明白。这很有趣，因为我觉得它解决了每一件让人如此不安的事情。它解决了你和她之间的裂痕，这看起来确实很可怕。然后它让你为那个在你那个年龄处于你位置的女孩解决了情况。
Yeah. At that age, I was really devastated by her action. That was like another watershed during a really ugly period of my life. And so to be able to not need to rub her nose in it as an adult, but to be able to resolve it in the way that we did, which is kind of like, I think, this charming lack of acknowledgment of what was actually going on, on both ends. I mean with hindsight now, I'm kind of putting it together and I feel like, oh, well, that's just completely OK. Neither of us needs to continue this relationship. This relationship is done now, finally, 35 years later.
是的。在那个年龄，我真的被她的行为摧毁了。那是我生命中一个非常丑陋时期的另一个分水岭。所以作为成年人，我不需要把她的鼻子擦在上面，而是能够以我们那样的方式解决它，我想这是一种关于当时究竟发生了什么的、迷人的不承认，在两端都是。我的意思是回顾现在，我有点把它拼在一起，我觉得，哦，嗯，那完全没问题。我们俩都不需要继续这种关系。这种关系现在结束了，终于，35年后。
Yeah, rest in peace.
是的，安息吧。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, our program was produced today by Jane Feltes and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Sean Cole, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Aaron Scott. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon is our office manager. Our music consultant is Jessica Hopper.
嗯，我们的节目今天由简·费尔特斯和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、肖恩·科尔、莎拉·科尼格、丽莎·波拉克、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助来自亚伦·斯科特。塞思·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。我们的音乐顾问是杰西卡·霍珀。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who says that he doesn't care what we say about it him here at the end of the program every week for one important reason--
WBEZ管理监督我们的节目由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他说他不关心我们每周结束时在这里说他什么，因为一个重要的原因——
I'm not here to make friends.
我来这里不是为了交朋友。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着《美国生活》的更多故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台。